foreign
and you know I'm a big apple Fanboy I
used to work at the Apple Store I look
like the just every Apple employee
you've ever seen and I'm a big fan of
Apple but I'm not a fan of their latest
program Apple pay later oh no it's here
folks and it's more dangerous than I
could even explain Jade you know why
because no one has to sign up for it
it's already built into your iPhone I
hate this I hate it already and I don't
even fully fully know what it is yet but
I kind of do so yeah we decided to make
this a surprise for Jade because I'm a
giant nerd so I'm just looking at this
stuff all day run down the facts for me
George so on Tuesday Apple launched
Apple pay later and it allows users to
split purchases into four interest-free
payments paid over six weeks with no
additional fee hate it so you buy
something for 100 bucks Apple pay while
you're checking out with Applebee says
hey why pay 100 bucks now you can pay 25
now and pay the other 75 over the course
of six weeks so you're paying 25 a week
for a hundred dollar purchase ish it's
it's over six weeks okay okay so there's
no interest or fees you're not paying
any more for the product so people out
there going well George Jade what's
wrong with this what's wrong with
there's so many things wrong with it
well keep going so here's what happens
uh prior to making a purchase Apple pay
later users can apply for a loan so I'm
glad they call out that it is a loan
people why God it's not alone between
fifty and a thousand dollars is what you
can use this for
you can use it for in-app purchases
online retailers that accept Apple pay
which is pretty much everyone these days
and so Apple conducts a soft credit
check they review a credit score and
they promise that this process won't
impact your score and if you're approved
you'll see all these payments in your
Apple wallet and so it's built into
Apple wallet will show exactly what you
owe and that's it you're applying for a
loan right at checkout and so as you
spend during the week you have all these
tiny little micro loans that you owe
money on now you're wondering what's the
catch right and because it's a zero
percent interest rate there's no fees
four payments over six weeks but here's
the catch Jade Apple makes money from
the transaction fees yes right the swipe
fees they're The Interchange fees so
when you make a purchase Apple gets a
cut of that and so Apple stays out of
The Fray here you know you're gonna hate
the bank the bank because what happens
when you have 17 payments and you can't
budget for that and so all of a sudden
you overdraft
because you didn't realize how much you
actually spent because in your brain you
spent 25 of that amount and now you
overdraft and that incurs a 35 fee 40
fee every single time it overdrafts I am
just beside myself I need for people to
understand if a hundred dollar look I
don't want you putting anything on
payments but if a hundred dollar
purchase or a 50 purchase you're like
you know what let me just spread this
out over six weeks you can't afford it
the VP of Apple pay her name's Jennifer
she said in the press release she said
well we wanna we built this because we
care about the Financial Health none of
our users that's what we we had the
Financial Health of our users in mind
and we want them to have flexibility
Jade that's all it is here's the thing
why spend all that money now they have
other bills to pay okay then let's let
the let's let the viewer weigh this or
The Listener I should say weigh this are
we going to listen to Jennifer who we've
already understood is getting a kickback
every time you go into debt or are you
gonna listen to Just Me and good old
George here on the radio who are making
no money off of this we just care about
your well-being we understand the damage
that debt does to people like you're
you're eroding your future for a 25
payment if you didn't have the hundred
dollars today or the extra 25 today
chances are you're not going to have it
next week you're not going to have the
week after that and then I'm just
thinking about just the generality of
this like if you're spreading money and
payment it's over weeks most people
aren't getting money every week most
people are on a you know they get paid
twice a month or once a month that sort
of thing like this is this is a bad bad
idea this is a bad bad bad idea George
here's a here's a financial concept oh
don't buy things you can't afford it's
so old-timey and so let me make this
very clear for all of you watching out
there Apple doesn't give a rip about
your Financial Health they exist to make
money they are launching this to make
money and steal market share from all
these buy now pay later companies that
are out there and and more than that
that's it you can tell by the the type
of debt this is who it's aimed at all
right the folks who've got a little bit
of money
they're not doing by now pay later
they're just buy now pay now it's by now
pay now this is aimed at lower income
people people who are living paycheck to
paycheck people who are already
struggling and they're making a bad
situation worse and I can't stand that
George I cannot stand companies who
their entire uh income structure is
based off of you or me failing you or me
defaulting you or me not being able to
make ends meet I hate companies that
earn money that way and I for one refuse
to participate in it and I hope that you
do too man this is this is terrible
stuff this is this is like the payday
lender this is like a digital payday
lender yeah but it looks better because
there's no interest in fees they go well
Jade it's a great option but here's
here's what Clara found and they brag
about this to retailers these buy now
pay later companies they're scum Clara
on their website brag to retailers that
consumers will spend up to 45 percent
more if you have buy now pay later on
your website
wow and here's the thing they're telling
you what they're doing to you and all of
you out there are going sucks to be them
and yet on Twitter if you look up any of
these companies like oh dang klarna
gonna kill me this month with all these
payments oh well YOLO I hate it this is
the mentality of a generation but here's
the thing and here's where the internet
gets us because
most I'm gonna be careful how I say this
most of us who use buy now pay later we
would not be willing to walk into a
payday loan store because you feel the
stigma you see it you know it's always
in that side of town or it's always you
know you don't want to walk into there
and you don't want to you know tell your
friend hey I'll be right back I'm just
going to the payday loan store you don't
want to tell them that but because it's
digitized it looks fancier it looks
sleek it's like hey it's just buy now
pay later but I guarantee you we
wouldn't do that if it was put in a
different format do you know what I'm
saying oh yeah I mean it lives in our
pocket it lives in our pocket there's no
shame it's just us and here's what it is
it's frictionless spending and the more
can conveniently make it the stupider we
get and the more broke we become it's
that simple yeah talk about that George
the frictionless spending because we
know the studies around that the
difference between how your brain
actually functions when you spend money
on with cash versus plastic versus
really nothing just the magic of the
interwebs right you go to the grocery
store with 200 cash from your envelope
system because you're working this plan
it physically pains you to hand over 200
in cash and you lose that money yeah
those centers in your brain light up
because it knows now you don't have it
the cashier has it when you use a card
any card debit card credit card you
don't feel any pain you swipe and then
you leave with that card and you leave
with your groceries and so your brain
says that didn't hurt at all and now
with our phones I don't even have to
pull out a card oh man I just hold my
phone over it and then the phone says
hey why spend 100 bucks I'll give you 75
off just spend 25 today we'll worry
about the other payments later
and what does that do it causes you to
be broke because you can't mentally or
physically budget for all of these
different payments coming out and in
your mind you're saying well I'm giving
myself flexibility no where you're
giving yourself is acid reflux down the
road when that thing overdraws on your
account and now you're getting dinged
for 40 bucks
a Time and that keeps happening the
overdraft is going to be so millions of
dollars from overdraft fees oh yeah and
Apple's genius in this because they go
well they're not going to be mad at us
we didn't do anything wrong it's on the
banks it's only users I want to know
okay and meanwhile their apple is the
one conducting the soft credit check yes
right they want to make sure you're in
good Financial standing if they're going
to loan you a thousand bucks oh my gosh
it's just so bad that in a second
somebody can say you're in good
Financial standing just in a second
think about think about this think about
how long it would take you for those of
you who you know don't really budget
don't really you're you're getting on
track with your money think how much
time it takes you to sit down you look
at your expenses you're listing
everything out and it takes time to see
really what the state of your finances
are absolutely but Apple knows Apple
knows in in three hot minutes whether or
not you can be loaned money they're
telling you hey we know the state of
your finances we think you can afford
this we're gonna issue you this line of
credit come on does that really does
that even I really want to love you
Apple but you're making it difficult and
I'm doing my best Ted lasso impression
with my track jacket today and it's it
really I was going to watch the new
episode tonight and I don't want to now
well they're just a taste in my mouth
we're jumping on that bandwagon of easy
money taking advantage of folks taking
advantage of the least of these
financials there's a wild idea for Apple
maybe make a better product if you want
more money maybe innovate a little
God Steve Jobs is rolling around in his
grave right now going really guys this
is what we've come to being in the
payday lender of America with Apple pay
later just say no your wallet your
budget your financial future will thank
you for item is the Ramsay show